hello everybody and welcome to let's
play nightmare house - I believe that we
are almost out of here
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe oh
you would come
oh no don't get dragged down another
door don't know oh oh no no you do
and finally oh man that sucks for that
guy what you get just suck it up finish
finish what you started don't take
breaths
oh here we go leave the way man
let us go
No
I'm shooting what do you do
I am opening fire
my fire is so open right now
let's all go get down all right are we
going now
what's going on
Oh
let it be let it be Oh with your fists
also badass I like that
Oh
oh man something stopped me I just know
it oh boy
all right let's keep going man go guy
headshot what do you got
we got sunny Jim poem banging oh hey
don't get up over there I am moving I'm
bossing me around are we are we really
that we're not dang it oh you want some
get some oh don't even try it man
try it bro dude done hey get off of me
torso oh I hate you torso
yeah you're welcome okay here oh no this
is where this guy dies and I get trapped
here forever this is all oh please let
us out
don't say that don't say that
Oh No Oh No
oh no oh no oh oh good golly oh good
good gracious
Oh what in to run faster guy
oh man oh no oh no no no no oh we're so
dead
so dead so dead so dad oh boy did you
survive somehow
oh no that's to call Requiem all
Oh evening for us I guess I can't
complete my objective okay responsible
for this mess Billy he's building
something I don't split your serger mom
I am so good it's like was name even
kill you
this place was abandoned for some time
now I recently checked all this activity
in fountain huh his name is dr. Romero
Billy find that [ __ ]
oh no sorry guys it lets still get my
throat's not doing so good but I'm gonna
keep going huh oh no Billy made me shut
down the transmitter so he could pump
out the signal that's causing all these
hallucinations
oh no oh damn it what why do I always
follow these guys's advice I knew he was
bad
I knew it I knew he was bad I'm on floor
nothing down I go oh I'm doing with that
let's see which rule of elevators
everywhere that man said
I am NOT the murderer you're the same as
ever intentionally killed anyone and I
don't plan on starting tonight uh-huh
therefore I want to give you the chance
to decide well you're dead
in just a moment this elevator is gonna
stop on the main level directly next to
the main entrance to the hospital uh-huh
if you want to spare yourself just leave
me in this hospital alone oh no way dude
if you're bound to determined to finally
kill me though just keep heading down
the elevator well I won't stop you from
coming just be warned I will be forced
to defend myself
Oh bring it on you cannot stand up to
this I don't care you send your crazy
girl lady to me okay don't go there
oh what the
okay parently you don't know the girl
doesn't want me to go so I'll bring it
on I am coming for you
oh you were so getting a shotgun into
the face
Oh ring this area is restricted to
senior level step you do not have a
problem organization please leave
shotgun is my office at your mouth shut
up you play the sax ah what was that
release I don't know whatever
bring it on I'll keep out no get
Oh Oh it's time Oh you come here Billy
I'm so ready I'm ready I'm ready
Oh here to cough yeah here spiky ball of
death oh it says oh I know it's your
wife isn't it
I knew it
let's see I can hear the elevator they
are on there we're down uh-huh uh-huh
yeah that's what I thought
oh oh here we go let's see this anyway
I'm out of options have to hide here
rumors going around bring it um wrong
like I came from where I was afraid of
she knows I'm here all your wife
abba-baba-baba
all mistake her choice
of course
on board while lost track
everyone's dead oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
hospital it's empty that guy that must
be me
No uh-huh uh-huh still watching him
that's where he just moved like me
um
finish me Oh bring it on you are so dead
cuz I met Joe uh-huh
okay he's waking up that's me oh yeah
can't stop me oh yes oh she is helping
me I knew it I knew it
oh I knew it oh yeah - scaring the crap
out of me but she was helping me yep
yeah oh don't even try it don't even try
it
radio room I knew come oh okay right
Billie I'm so gonna shoot you in the
face
yeah oh she is so predictable oh yes
yes yep okay all right oh you're so dead
you're so dead guy oh you're so oh
what's this
I don't know what that is that's his
machine or something okay we got here
well that's always talking to me all
right okay let's see
whoops sorry for that snub your
computer's okay here
I'll bring it on guy I'll bring it on
Billy Oh Billy you're nowhere as near as
awesome but I'm just gonna kill you the
same as I did the last Billy shotgun
shell yes okay kid oh yeah
357 open this axe bring it on bring it
on
oh yeah I'm so ready let me just
double-check something I think I may
have forgotten something
um I was in here I saw the picture
there's another picture sold oh that's
the house okay same picture uh core
results okay I'm wondering if there's
like some information I might need to
know beforehand stupid stick figures
eyeballs
the game Oh doc I lost the game I lost
dammit dammit
okay why why yeah why
all right um don't seem to be anything
else here NDE the truth oh look at that
yay nothing orange roses oh Emily Emily
that's her name okay alright I think
that's I think that's everything okay um
I gotta cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you
guys in the next part I don't remember
what part it is but it's the next one
trust me on that one of nightmare house
- thank you so much for watching bye bye